foreign
for linear codes so my name is Fernando
um this is going to be based on joint
work with Leonardo correliano and Chris
Jones so Leonardo here and increase
and the fundamental question that we are
looking at here is what is the geometry
of a discrete space like after today
right um
and uh to talk about geometry it will be
nice to talk to fix a metric and let's
take the usual Heming metric that we are
used to so that's uh very philosophical
question but we can make it more
concrete right and one way of making
this concrete is to consider the
following question so what is the
maximum size of a set of points such
that the pairwise distance is at least
the
right so here we we have the space of
choose then and we are asking for a
subset of points in this space and you
are imposing a minimum distance a
condition so
there wise the points need to be at
least just as D apart okay so this is a
very basic question that you can ask
about these discrete spaces
and this is related to coding Theory so
this collection of points is nothing
more than a code N is a subset of points
in this space defines a code and this
lower bound on the pairwise jsons is
known as the minimum distance or the
distance of the code so what you are
asking is what is the maximum size of a
code on this space after which then such
that the minimum Jesus that you're
denoting by this Delta is at least D and
we give this name
um the a2nd or concreteness and you are
asking what is the value what is this
quench what is the maximum size of a
code of blockline fan and minimum
distance did and sometimes determining
those questions exactly can be hard so
let's try to explore a simple question
and the simple question is what is the
synthetic growth of this quench let's
say that we we have n going to infinity
and if you are interested in
understanding how how fast is the growth
of this this function here okay
and uh let's define a little bit more
notation that that's going to be
convenient one notation that's very
convenient is the symbolic rate so here
you are given a Delta that's uh let's
say a constant between zero and a half
and we are looking at this point you're
taking the limit of the log of the size
of h u n with with distance Delta times
n and we we normalize so we are taking
the log of the size of the code so this
is in this regime it's meant to be
exponential
um in the end and and then you're
normalizing by n so roughly the the
synthetic rate is capturing this
exponential growth of a code so a code
grows uh the actual order terms in this
form so two to the symbolic rate
times in so there is an exponential
growth in this regime that Delta is a
constant and the natural question is can
you at least determine this asymptotic
group right um ignoring lower order
factors here very good uh and one thing
that's very surprising is that we do not
know so this is synthetic growth is is
not known so we do not know how this the
size of the code grows so it could be
the case that a code is of the size or a
cold potential might be a bit larger or
potentially the largest code could be
much much larger than and we do not know
we do not know precisely
okay and I think this is a mathematical
problem an interesting mathematical
problem in sales but colds are can be
useful uh in practice right if you want
to protect our data against corruption
you might be interested in using codes
and uh if you do not understand uh the
best codes that you can use you might be
using more riddance you might be
requiring more storage to to protect our
data so this can can be useful in the
communication you might be exchanging
more bits than we need right um and also
this may occur of course in terms of
energy so this is a fundamental question
reality tends to be much more
complicated but at least in the
theoretical level we need it's as a
question that would be very interesting
to understand right what exactly are
optimal codes
okay and this direction is not there yet
and it could have potential practical
implications
very good but what is known so uh there
is this famous curve in coding tier
that's called the Gilbert version of
bound uh it dates back to the 50s and it
give us what is achievable what is
possible so combinations of rate and
distance below this green curve they are
possible okay
and it's a very simple argument
um and those are the parameters of
random calls if you take a points at
random in the space or random linear
code you get this parameter so H2 here
is the binary entropy but it's not very
important what it is at this point
and in terms of upper bound we we have a
curve saying that the combinations of
rate and this is above this curve they
are impossible
and this is due to Michael Ellis Rodney
Rams in Welsh from the 70s and it gives
this dysfunction here again it's not
important the exact expression but what
is important here is that we have a
noticeable Gap right between the lower
bound and the upper bound
and that should be precise that are
actually two
uh bounce through Upper bounds here
depending on whether the distance is
more larger but let's only look at this
one this one is the best one for larger
citizens okay very good and uh one point
that uh Things become very clear is when
you go to very large distance that for
binary code is GSS hat minus Epsilon and
in this regime you can see that the
centroid rate here the upper bound on it
is is Epsilon Square log 1 over Epsilon
and the the ubertos move bone tell us
that it's at least Epsilon squared so we
saw we see that uh this uh as you
approach closer to a half the the base
of this exponential growth is somehow
diverging right the the upper lower
bound are getting further and further
apart as we approach this uh a half so
we really do not know what is the the
size of a code we do not understand this
exponential uh growth at all or we only
have these bounds but okay
and what a surprise is that even if you
restrict if you ask the code I wanted
instead of looking at all codes let's
restrict our attention to linear codes
and linear codes are extremely important
potential is the most important broad
class of codes that we we use during
practice and you can ask the question
what about bonds for linear calls now
I'm giving you this restriction and the
bounds remain the same so not at least
the non-bounds not nothing is known to
improve here this regime and then
let's take a step back and then let's
see what what is this uh the upper bound
the upper Bound in terms of techniques
it comes from analyzing a linear
programs of those hearted
and since we are they came from
analyzing LPS this is called the lp
bound or mrw or op bound okay and uh if
you are trying to design an MLB let's
say for linear codes uh one third
natural way is is through
cook variables that they try to capture
the number of code words let's say that
sees their code the number of code words
of Hemingway died
then the objective function that's going
to be a relaxation for for the size of
the code here right it's going to be the
sum of AI from zero all the way to end
so we are some the number of code words
of all having weights
uh it's a linear code so we know that
zero needs to be there right and it
occurs only once there is only one zero
we have Jesus constraints so in a linear
code whenever you see Heming weight
between one and the the distance minus
one you know that it is a violation you
cannot see code words here so all those
variables here from one object D minus
one they need to be zero so those are
the distance constraints
and the AIS you're trying to pick up a
linear program they actually need to be
no negative
hey so this gives an LP but it doesn't
seem that you're imposing too many
constraints right uh and uh indeed it's
possible to impose more constraints so
the the AIS they satisfy some
inequalities that we are calling here
culture constraints or they are also
called McWilliams inequalities and they
give us some relations that uh if you
take some sum of the AIS with some
coefficients here it needs to be no
negative and those coefficients are
known as the crotchic polynomials here
and and this is somehow trying to
capture uh what would be the this the
AIS are known as the weight distribution
of of the code and it's trying to
between fours that the AIS that you are
seeing in this relaxation they are
somehow close to coming from the code
and these LPs they can be a bit tricky
because if you look at the crotch equal
Norm with the family of orthogonal
polynomials and it's quite oscillatory
right and the magnitudes are all over
the place so it's not uh it's not
completely trivial to to see what's
going on with this LP
okay very good so this is that they'll
start op and this is the technique
behind the state of the art at this
point
and we may ask it it's a relaxation for
the problem how well does it perform is
it a good relaxation it's capturing the
feasible region in a nice way and giving
tight values or somehow it's not
capturing it very well the true
Solutions are very interior to this
polytope and uh it's a poor
approximation so and we do not know so
do not knowing which case we are
but what we do know is that uhmogynistic
show that uh from the outside LP you
cannot extract a bound better than
Epsilon Square Times log 1 over Epsilon
and recall that this is essentially the
mrrw bound
so if you believe that this bound them
are the rebound is not tight you would
need stronger techniques stronger
methods than the Del sart LP alone okay
so um and then you may ask how can you
get stronger techniques right that
relaxation maybe maybe tight or not we
do not know but how can we get
techniques that are provably stronger
and this one solution will be go higher
order in the higher order what do you
mean by that uh one key ideas in the
authority you looked at um the hand
weight of individual points right uh and
now we can look at tuples or of words
and consider the Heming weight of the
sum of all subsets of it we can look at
the Heming weight of this guy and this
guy the hidden weight of their sum the
hand weight of the sum of every every
guy so you can look at the heaving
weight of the sum of every guy and since
our code is linear right if this comes
from the top of code words we can impose
you can look at the same weight and if
it's between one and just as minus one
we know that it's a violation right it
can't be there so the the idea is going
to be precisely explored that explore
this this interaction of a higher order
that's called the an L Point bound but
but also explore export them
the linearity of the code to impose more
constraints
and indeed if you do that you can come
up with a high hierarchy that
generalizes the those rtlp it coincides
with it in the first level and uh it
revolves around the notion of
configuration it's not that important to
what it is but if you see here this
problem it's syntactically very similar
to those rtlp but now you have things
that are higher order so here we have
the multivered crotch polynomials uh but
but synthetically it's very very close
to start open
and it's certainly more complicated but
why do you think this program is is
interesting uh one reason is that it
coincides with the state of the art
technique in the first level right um
there is this uh structural similarity
of those art LP and that that far these
problems essentially the only convex
problem that we we know how channelized
theoretically
um it probably converts you should and
one good thing is that you're having
this x-ray structure but it provably
converges the correct value and that
that's that's going to be quite
important so uh in a previous work we
will show that this hierarchy as the
level becomes larger than N squared it
converges to what would be the correct
size for linear codes so linear means
that the same thing of h1d but for
linear codes so it's going to converge
it's not going to give in this proof we
do not prove that it converts exactly
but it gives the exact value but it will
converge as the level gets larger and
you need a level that's at least same
squared that that's very good it seems
that this hierarchy might be I don't
know a stronger technique that we may be
looking for
and uh but some things were not uh
parameter wise they are not exactly what
would expect who would expect that uh
with level about 10 we should already be
able to to extract the the True Value
and recover it exactly
and this work is doing precisely that we
are refining your understanding of this
hierarchy and uh and showing that indeed
at 11 we recover things exactly
and the plan what we learned here is
that uh
we gave a new uh perspective on this
higher kit we looked at this hierarch
from the new angle based on pseudo
probabilities and from this new angle we
we could see that indeed it had this
exact completeness it it recovered the
value exactly okay and this problem is
very reaching symmetries especially when
you go to higher levels that there are a
lot of symmetries that you can explore
and one symmetry that's going to be
important in this new perspective is to
consider subspaces consider the the
symmetry of those programs around
subspaces
and let's try to go over the the
chronological hierarchy and uh in a
different form but actually in a little
bit more detail so here what you're
going to have you're going to have a
solution but now index by tuples in uh
after today in
to the L and the intention is that if
you had a code this would be capturing
the product of indicators are all those
words here in the code so this would be
the ideal solution and if you want to
the objective function would be some of
all possible purpose and then asking
this question so it would give us in
this case the size of the code to the L
uh it's going to be a linear call so
here the the all zero stop we should
have C1 the normalization now you can
impose the GSS constraints that we
mentioned so whenever you look at the
span of the this type of vectors here if
there is a vector such that its Heming
weight is between one and and D minus
one we are allowed to say that this is
zero this is not allowed to happen
because of minimum distance
very good we also have a inequalities a
corresponding to Fourier coefficients we
know that uh if you see this ax as some
function of tapos we know that when you
compute this Fourier transform we need
to see something that's not negative
okay there is a reason for that it's
essentially because the do of a linear
codes that the Fourier transformer for
linear codes proportional to to choose
an educator if it's dude they did the
indicator of Fourier transform of the
indicator of a code this proportional
indicator of its do so that that's the
reason but let's not discuss it further
and uh
since the the solution that we have in
mind has this form if you have two
tuples that display in the same space we
should put the same value right um very
good so those are Subspace symmetries in
our problem and they also this is
supposed to be an indicator so it should
be a greater or equal to zero so we we
have this this program here
and very good so and since it's a linear
code right this would be asking is this
pain of this this code word these words
in in our code right that's containing
our code
so that's uh you can replace by that but
this is a relaxation so what you're
asking is some pseudo probability some
relaxation of this indicator to say is a
span of this type of words in our code
very good and now since we have this uh
uh this constraints the Subspace
symmetries we can rewrite this this
whole program in terms of of these
variables the variables indicating that
are given some space s is contained in
our intended code so we have those
pseudo probabilities here and for every
Subspace s so can we write this program
in terms of these variables but Subspace
containments it it's nice but it even
better than that would be to have oh
that pseudo probabilities indicating
whether our code is equal to True given
space that that's even easier to to
reason about write and analyze so you
can try to do precisely that right so
here the we can express that s
containing C is the same as
so the probability is the same as the
sum of all the solar probabilities of
all the guys that uh are large or equal
than S right um so this is the
probability of s being contained in the
chord is is the sum here
and uh using these these relations we
can do we can think that we we have a
the whole set of subspaces right uh now
we have variables uh for a Subspace we
we have a variable and the way we can do
a mobile transform and the program that
was written in terms of these variables
you can now write in terms of this this
quality variables here very good so we
have a new formulation which our
variables are precisely this pseudo
probabilities
very good okay so uh if you do that you
can write that program in this form uh
we we have this new objective function
you have this normalization constraint
we have this json's constraints if the
Subspace has a some word that violates
minimum jsons we have therefore here
coefficients become this constraint and
you also have some non-negativity
constraint
and Let's do let's simplify a bit the
notation so instead of carrying this
equals to see let's just say that's to
the probability of s I mean this
and okay we have this program it's it's
nice because now I do not have crazy
alternation before we had I don't know
four here coefficients can hear of
assign alternations right and the
formulation and now all the coefficients
here they are non-egative
right there and uh if you look at this
program it you have a feeling okay now
we have this pseudo probabilities
there's times one they satisfy the
digistance constraints so it should be
close to being done right uh but
unfortunately that's not the case so
that the pseudo probability is one thing
that it's no longer here they can be
negative so the variables that we had
previously they were greater recording
zero but now these variables they can be
negative and you need to be careful
about that okay
very good so you're not quite there and
if you expect the this poorly talk in
most cases you're going to have some
points such that this pseudo probability
is negative so the the feasible region
of this polytop has some
some points that do not correspond to
code words to two codes okay so
something valid points here so that's
what happened and you might be afraid
you might think that it is all lost
right and not exactly right so the hope
that we we have now is that it should
look at the optimal points so we can
look at the gradient here the of the
objective function and we we can hope
that at least that um our optional
Solutions might correspond to to convex
combination of true codes okay and if
that's the case you'll be quite happy
and and that's indeed what we can show
can show that optional Solutions
correspond to consonation of true
Solutions through
codes
very good and the towards doing that we
are going to make this program a little
bit easier to to handle and the one
thing that was important and is to relax
before we had Jesus constraints right
whenever a space had a non-zero Vector
that violated minimum Jesus we zeroed
out this Vector now we are only going to
we are going to look at the dimension of
the largest uh space that is allowed
with this distance and we know that any
space that has a larger Dimension a
dimension might have a violating Vector
right because this is the the
maximum dimension of a space that
respects this distance all spaces of
Dimension One and above
one plus this destination they're going
to be violating spaces so they need to
be zero so if you have these constraints
only you might have dropped right that
there might be some space of lower
Dimension that also have violations
right um so you somehow removed some of
the constraints and the value of this
relaxed program can only go up right
there so if you can show that this
converge the True Value we are good
because with this relaxation the the
objective value can only go up
uh very good and uh recorded the main
theorem that you want to prove is that
this hierarchy is going to recover
exactly uh the the value of the size of
a in your code the maximum size of a
linear code when L is greater it
coordinate okay so that that's what
you're running for here
now let's give a proof sketch so the the
idea is just to give a flavor right
they're not going to go overall steps
but let's see how this can how one can
show this and let's start with a an
optional solution right let's say that
we have a pseudo probability our
variables are those uh so the
probabilities and let's say that we
start with an auto solution for our
program
okay very good we can look at this
solution you can look at the guys that
are non-zero right the the support and
you can take s mean to be a space of
minimum dimension in the support of this
guy okay so one picture that's going to
be important for us is that we are going
to look at this bow set of subspaces uh
it's uh under conclusion right the usual
inclusion and here have a space of
Dimension zero I did the full space
let's say a space of Dimension uh K
naught and uh very good and that we may
have S Meme here okay and let's start
with the case that the dimension of s
mean is precisely K naught so the
dimension of s mean is precisely
cannot and what it means is a space of
minimum Dimension it means that
everything below it by definition need
to be and it should have value zero
right there so all these guys here below
they have value zero very good uh by our
restrictions or Dimension restrictions
all the guys all the space is above
okay zero they are going to be zero
they're going to have value zero very
good and then we are left with with the
guys that have Dimension precisely K
naught and if we inspect this solution
here this guy here or what it's saying
that if you consider let's say s mean
here we are going to be summing let's
say U is equal to s p you're going to be
summing all the guys below it right um
and uh we know that everything else is
zero so the only no zero guy that may
appear here uh is this mean so it forces
it to be no negative and similarly all
the other guys in this level because
everything else is zero they did this
guy's image be really good on zero and
uh now we indeed have a probability
distribution because they are all
greater liquid and zero and they sound
q1 and this this is enough we we are
done we have a true probability
distribution in this case very good now
let's consider the case that the
dimension of this minimum space and the
support is the 3 particularly smaller
than
k0 so let's say that this is a our s
mean
then the dimension is strictly smaller
than K naught and here let's consider
all the guys in the poster that are one
dimensionable right so this guy's
contact this guy contains that this
guy's contained as mean this guy
contains a smooth and so on and it's one
dimensionable let's fix our attention on
those guys
and uh very good do we know that this
guy is different than zero and this
restriction again since this is the mean
guy it forces it to be strictly positive
so we know that we have some positive
players here
let's represent this position as by
these dots and the idea is to transfer
this Mass up so we're going to move it
up and redistribute equally to to the
guys above
very good and the claim is that if you
do that you're going to have a new uh
solution and the solution issue feasible
or for our program it's a case an ad so
I'm not going to do it now but let's
give some intuition as to
uh why this would be good to do and if
you look at this objective function it
favors we have a s to there right at the
size of the spatial it it favors
replacing mass or on Spaces that have
larger Dimension because it's going the
coefficient is going to be much larger
so when you move the mass up we are
somehow then we can show formula that
that you can increase this objective
function if you had some Polish mass and
SMS me we moved up uh the the the the
trade-off and the level would be such
that it strictly increases and improves
this objective function and that can be
right because we started with an optimal
solution so this is a contradiction and
we we are done in here
very good
okay
so that that finishes the the sketch
and the the title and the title we
promised that this will be a
completeness of LP hierarchy so
we mentioned one hierarchy but there is
also another hierarchy so concurrently
to us a library millionaire that they
were playing with Sim ID is playing if
we hear analysts and they come up with
um a slightly different hierarchy that's
different uh in one important point they
observe that uh there are more
inequalities that you can place in this
program so when you have a linear code
not only the the Fourier coefficients
need to be no magnitude but also partial
for here coefficients in the sense that
you have this product space right and in
some coordinates you can take a
character in some other coordinates you
can take the indicator and this needs to
be a non-negative for a linear code so
it allows to include more restrictions
which is great and they also consider
the different objective function right
and
from our previous work a year ago this
we cannot we knew the approx made
complete as we knew that our higher
converges right at that level N squared
but that proved completely it stopped
working for this guy because that proof
crucially relied on accounting argument
uh
and that that breaks for this objective
function so this hierarchy even though
it's extremely bit similar right and it
has more constraints it was not clear
that it was also complete based on the
previous result but but now using the
pseudo probability for formulation can
also show that yes it's also complete it
does allow us to look at the this higher
can prefix that completeness by a level
and and these extra restrictions they
are also nice in the sense that uh in in
our hierarch the polytope has some
points that the pseudo probabilities can
be negative but in their hierarchy all
those sort of probabilities you can show
that they are greater recognized zero so
you really have a probability
distribution also the probability is our
probabilities so this convex uh the the
physical body top is indeed the convex
full of convex of true Solutions okay
very good
so that's uh our new instruction
understanding about this hierarchies
um of course there's much work to be
done in terms of analyzing them and so
on but that that's all for today and uh
thank you very much for your taste